بينما تخسر اوكرانيا معركه في حربها مع
روسيا على الجبهه الاخرى تستعد لمعارك
اعتى فانضمام طائرات اف 16 الى سلاح الجو
الاوكراني كبديل عن طائرات صوفياتيه اكل
الدهر عليها وشرب هي نقطه تحول اخرى في
مسار الحرب الاوكرانيه
لطالما رفضت واشنطن تقديم مقاتلات شرسه
الى اوكرانيا خوفا من التصعيد مع روسيا او
حتى خوفا من تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل
بها الى موسكو وفق السي انا
معتبره ان حاجه تكييف تقتصر على حمايه
البنيه التحتيه وصد الهجمات الروسيه لكن
الضغوط من قبل البنتاجون والكونغرس
الامريكي على مدى اشهر على الاداره
الامريكيه غيرت الدفه بالاتجاه المعاكس
قرار يجسد النظره الامريكيه المتغيره تجاه
الوضع الاوكراني فبينما تنفذ صواريخ كييف
تزداد الحاجه لحمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيه
لكن الامداد بمقاتلات من نوع اف 16 يدل
على تصور واشنطن لمستقبل الحرب
واستمراريتها ربما لسنوات في اوكرانيا حتى
مع التوجه الى حل التفاوض
بالاضافه للتشكيك بالهجوم المضاد الذي
تستعد له
تفوق جوي سيفرض القوه والغلبه لصاحبه
تحاول اوكرانيا الوصول اليه واختصرته على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا في خمس نقاط الحاجه لتطوير
سلاح الجو الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
التي لا تستطيع انظمه الدفاع الجوي ردها
دعم القوات البريه والتقليل من خسائرها
على الارض بتوفير الحمايه الجويه لهم
حمايه صادرات الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود من
خلال تامين خط تصدير
مواجهه مباشره بين السلاحين الامريكي
والروسي لاختبار القدرات
الحفاظ على الحدود الاوروبيه من ترسيم
روسي قد يغير جغرافيه القاره حرب تحولت من
نزاع على الحدود الجغرافيه الى حرب
استنزاف بين الطرفين الفائز فيها هو الطرف
الذي يستمر في التزويد اللوجستي لاطول
فتره ممكنه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخ بيج
والقريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات